I want to say how delighted my family my
colleagues and I ought to be in Norway
this is for most of us our first trip to
Scandinavia in 1964 Martin Luther King
jr. was awarded the Nobel Peace Prize
for his nonviolent campaign against
discrimination the hill sir Martin
Luther King edad then among some alder
ID coups in true foreign voters to
comfort
some are leaders in true but things that
mahogany ancien Mohammed on sale Ron
Schara through with murdered only given
are an EKG actor till then ever barely
shameful for Frieden R&R school students
Nobel Committee it Fred's prison for or
meeting under the fear or sixty most
importantly understood it was a victory
not just what person but for a movement
when the people at the headquarters got
the news of the Nobel Peace Prize this
shout was we won we won it wasn't just
Martin won and he shared that sentiment
he in fact he felt guilty about the
notion that one person could take credit
for a movement and and almost
immediately announced that the prize
money was going to be shared among all
the civil rights organizations that he
wasn't going to keep that money for
himself the Nobel Peace Prize the
diploma and the gold medal
[Music]
a people in our country from the
President on down felt that this award
represented a tribute to America and
certainly a tribute to the thousands and
millions of gallant individuals who have
been engaged in the struggle for freedom
and justice in our country what was
terribly important about the Nobel Prize
coming to dr. King was that that fact
introduced our movement to an
international community in 1966 Harry
Belafonte performed a benefit concert
for dr. King at the Royal Swedish opera
house in Stockholm when all of Pama
invited us to come the king of Sweden
took on being come being the patron of
that concert ladies and gentlemen the
Nobel Peace Prize winner the Reverend
dr. Martin Luther King
[Applause]
I'm deeply moved by this magnificent
demonstration of goodwill and support
for the cause of racial justice in
America never before has an entire
nation come forth with such a total
commitment to our cause
Martin Luther King and his movement had
now become an international matter the
State Department got very upset because
we had taken what they considered to be
a family of fear black oppression and
that we were exposing it to the world at
large they were trying to win the hearts
and minds of people and this
competitiveness they felt with the
Russians of the Soviet Union and as long
as there was a black protest then trying
to sell the world that we were the most
democratic nation though did not sit
well dr. King understood this very
clearly and exercised that advantage
with great enthusiasm the world over we
will able be able to sing in a cosmic
past tense in the not-too-distant future
we have overcome we have overcome deep
in my heart I did believe we would
overcome someday thank you other
concerts were organized around Europe
spreading the message and the
development of civil rights to a broader
audience
[Music]
you